madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal en avion d'air caraïbes s'écrase
à l'atterrissage à saint-barthélemy
bilan de la catastrophe 20 morts la
plupart d'entre eux étaient des
touristes venant de la métropole
les causes du drame sont encore
inconnues l'élection ce matin de
bertrand delanoë qui devient le premier
maire de bouche de la capitale
l'itinéraire d'un militant proche de
lionel jospin qui fut ancien député du
xviiie il est également sénateur de
paris
opération d'envergure à tetovo en
macédoine les forces gouvernementales
auraient repris le contrôle des
principales positions de la guérilla
une force sans précédent appuyées par
des chars et des hélicoptères et puis
dans quelques heures la cérémonie des
oscars à hollywood grand favori le film
américain gladiateurs et quelques
espoirs français juliette binoche pour
le chocolat et le goût des autres
d'agnès jaoui la grande majorité des
passagers du vol d'air caraïbes était
français aucun survivant après
l'accident du bimoteur qui s'apprêtait
hier à se poser sur la piste de saint
barthélemy d'un accès particulièrement
difficile il faut d'ailleurs une
qualification spéciale pour les pilotes
une enquête judiciaire a été ouverte les
causes de l'accident sont encore
incertaines apparemment lors l'avion
aurait fait un demi tour lors d'une
première approche avant de s'écraser sur
une habitation
olivier carol
impressionnant spectaculaire mais disait
ton aux touristes sans grand danger
aucun visiteur de saint-barthélemy ne
peut oublier l' atterrissage sur l'île
juste après la montagne
l'avion qui pique vers la piste à chaque
fois l'impression d'être un miraculé
hier vers 16h30 ce miracle ne s'est pas
produit un bimoteur s'est écrasé sur
sept maisons à flanc de rocher à
quelques centaines de mètres seulement
de la piste à bord 17 passagers 16
français et un américain et deux membres
d'équipage tous ont trouvé la mort ainsi
qu'un occupants de l'habitation
l'appareil de la compagnie air caraïbes
effectué la liaison régulière depuis
saint martin un vol de dix minutes à
peine
robuste fiable mais de conception
ancienne le bimoteur de havilland était
le plus vieil appareil de la compagnie
bien connue des autres pilotes
ce que je peux affirmer ici c'est que je
me suis effectivement posé quelques
minutes avant lui que les conditions
météorologiques il est tout à fait
normal que le commandant de bord
monsieur jean pol cher pour que je
collais cette semaine via met à l'homme
d'expérience donc je ne peux pas penser
qu'il s'agisse des facteurs humains
le bureau enquêtes accidents du bourget
a immédiatement envoyé quatre experts
leur tâche sera difficile
l'avion accidenté ne disposait pas de
boîtes noires tout repose donc sur
l'examen des débris et le récit des
témoins du crash et un prêt midi j'étais
en train de faire de la voile dans la
baie de public et puis on a vu l'avion
qui a fait 10 1/2 tour juste avant de
passer la tourmente qui est revenu vers
public donc chose qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir
et puis d'un seul coup apparemment il a
décroché puis il est parti en vrille
elle est tombée d'un coup que s'est il
passé exactement les familles des
victimes arrivés sur place ne sont pas
les seuls à vouloir là
c'est toute une île orienté entièrement
vers le tourisme les joignable
uniquement par avion qui attend
désormais les résultats de l' enquête
alors qu'un peu partout en france
l'heure est à la décrue s'est une
nouvelle fois l'île et vilaine qui
payent un lourd tribut à ces inondations
entretenu depuis hier par de fortes
pluies les pompiers sont intervenus plus
de 200 fois depuis hier dans le
département la ville de redon semble ce
soir protégées comme le monde ce
reportage d'olivier sous ces jours-ci
dipri a comme une allure de venise de
l'ouest en temps ordinaire la rue des
gabelous c'est une jolie ruelles du
village
mais ce dimanche après midi c'est en
cuissardes que patrick et son voisin
doivent accéder à leurs maisons à
l'intérieur les travaux sont suspendus
ils reprendront quand la rivière le
voudra bien
et les blacks commence à faire un peu la
tête
regardé ça ce matin c'est qu'ils sont
tous frais abaisser ses frais faire à
cet effet ya quinze jours c'est un petit
peu la galère
la galère aussi pour michel son voisin
mais cette fois ci pas question de se
laisser surprendre dès mercredi la
déménager toute la cuisine il valait
mieux on l'a démontée j'y vais demander
l'avis jours ont fait de la remontée
bon tout est neuf bien sûr puisque guy
prix en est à sa 5ème cru en quelques
mois
et à en croire la bonne vieille sagesse
des anciens ce n'est pas fini les
anciens par rapport aux lunettes haut
dans une audi qu on arrête des droits
cette inondation alors là on est déjà à
cinq ans encore on va pas loin de ce
qu'ils ont dit des crues à répétition
qui finissent par porter sur les nerfs
de certains riverains
je suis parti trois semaines de sujets
racketter les plans mais je crois que
c'est déjà arrivé une fois autour de
guipry certains villages isolés se sont
vidés de leurs habitants depuis la fin
de la semaine
nul ne sait quand les eaux commenceront
à baisser même si la météo est plus
clémente cet après midi en seine
maritime le fleuve continuent de monter
surtout à la hauteur d'elbeuf différents
points noirs le long de la seine avec à
paris les voies sur berge totalement
inondées du coup les services de la
police judiciaire le fameux 36 quai des
orfèvres a été privé de courant les eaux
ayant envahi le sous sol
une situation préoccupante également
dans les yvelines où les crues alimenter
là aussi par de fortes pluies ont obligé
l'évacuation de plusieurs zones
d'habitation dans leur l'eau continue de
monter plusieurs des marques
départementales sont encore coupées à la
circulation à total le niveau de l'eau
est monté la nuit dernière par endroits
du 8 à 10 cm en revanche un retour à la
normalisation presque avec une très
forte décrue du rhône et de la saône la
cellule de crise à d'ailleurs été levée
il y a tout juste deux heures dans cette
région qui vivaient les pieds dans l'eau
il ya une semaine les habitants de la
petite commune de saunière se sont
rendus aux urnes en tracteur ce matin
olivier galzi sylvain de bas au volant
le maire son tracteur fait aujourd'hui
office de transport des lecteurs
françoise et robert sont isolées depuis
huit jours par le doubs en crue mais
robert lui aurait quand même préféré
aller voter en vélo la benne à lecteurs
c'est pas son truc
et il le fait savoir
j'en ai chanté 30 ans
mais moi je les en déloger ajouté
et puis quand le franc je n'allais pas
de dignité
c'est pour catastrophe
c'est important d'aller voter
aujourd'hui pour vous oui mais oui
cette surprenante machine de guerre
électorale là tout même eu un mérite à
saunier 80 habitants l'abstention pour
ce second tour des municipales n'a été
aujourd'hui que de 10% autre village
autres maires nous sommes en bord de
saône et la première habitante de la
commune est venue constater les dégâts
causés par la crue
j'ai demandé mal est répartie pour
demander à le supporter saône-et-loire
de nous classer communes sinistrées
je pense que de toute façon on a déjà
été communiste listes 99 alors a
fortiori en 2001 où la crue a été
beaucoup plus importante
après dix jours passés sous les eaux de
la saône ginni retrouve enfin son bitume
mais pour les pompiers de la région tout
reste à faire
nicolas de karusi de garde de sceaux
rapido libye et maintenant redescendre
d'immeubles nettoyer les habitations
c'est à dire que
on a autant de travail nous aujourd'hui
et il pourra venir que pendant la crise
on travaille à peu près une bonne
semaine à vos romans
une semaine c'est aussi le temps qu'il
faudra à la saône pour réintégrer
totalement son lit enfin pour clore ce
chapitre des inondations avait les
planchistes a été emporté par le rhône
en crue hier soir son corps n'a pas été
retrouvé
c'est avec un peu de recul et de
distance qu'il faut tenter de faire le
point sur ce deuxième foyer de fièvre
aphteuse découvert vendredi soir en
seine-et-marne des informations souvent
contradictoires laisser penser que le
négociant de mayenne aurait fraudé ce
soir jean glavany lui-même lance un
appel au civisme et la transparence de
tout mouvement concernant les animaux
notamment ceux qui proviennent de
grande-bretagne valérie ermite thierry
breton voici l'exploitation du négociant
de la barouge gondouin vers qui tous les
regards sont aujourd'hui tournés
y at il eu fraude négligence manque de
civisme
la question est sur toutes les lèvres
mais les réponses divergent le négociant
de mayenne qui nie toute fraude pouvant
être à l'origine du deuxième cas de
fièvre aphteuse en seine et marne a été
conforté hier soir par la justice elle
même
nous n'avons absolument aucun élément
qui permette d'incriminer les époux au
bout au plan juridique c'est à dire de
leur ont reproché d'avoir fraudé à la
loi et fraude et la réglementation qui a
été mise en place pour lutter contre les
épizooties jean-françois reboul et
négociants de mayenne semble collaborer
à l'enquêté de gendarmerie
reste que ça n'aurait peut-être pas
toujours été le cas et notamment avec
les services vétérinaires
ce soir jean glavany ne veux citer
personne mais maintient sa position
ouais je maintiens qu'il eut trop
d'heures et sont vides c'est une
personne en particulier
je m'attaquais les fraudes et on verra
ça tranquillement dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent en tout cas moi ce
que je veux dire c'est que en tout état
de cause ce dont on a besoin nous pour
faire face à des épisodes 6 de cette
ampleur et cette difficulté c'est une
coopération d'une sorte de civisme de
l'ensemble des éleveurs et surtout de
l'ensemble des négociants qui doivent
coopérer avec les services de l'état
notamment que les services vétérinaires
nous avons besoin de cette coopération
pour sauver le cheptel français
ça c'est une réalité objective
à l'autre bout de la chaîne lors
empochant l'éleveur de seine et marne
victimes du deuxième foyer de fièvre
aphteuse certificat vétérinaire à
l'appui il tient à plaider sa bonne foi
certificat vétérinaire et du 22 qui
était entendu par les gendarmes de la
mayenne
hier soir la brigade des recherches de
la gendarmerie de recherche de la balle
pendant deux heures et des moutons vont
rentrer en toute légalité
reste que la fièvre aphteuse que l'on
pensait presque maîtrisé en france c'est
bel et bien propager de la mayenne en
seine et marne
la fdsea entend porter plainte contre x
pour comprendre et identifier les
responsables aussitôt connu ce deuxième
cas de fièvre aphteuse un large
périmètre de sécurité a entouré d'abord
l'exploitation puis tout le département
a roissy des tapis désinfectant été mise
en place alors que les centres équestres
encore le parc que walt disney mettait
en quarantaine tous les animaux laetitia
legendre philip k
désormais à l'aéroport de roissy où fait
le ménage sous ses semelles tous les
passagers en provenance ou à destination
de grande bretagne sont invités à les
désinfecter sur ces tapis des
contaminants un passage obligé qu'il est
parfois un peu perplexe juste normal de
le faire bien levé de la région je
vienne et nous rachetons pappardelle
toute façon marche du sud en asie
village devrait même pas remarqué alors
mesures de sécurité aussi dans le parc
eurodisney situé à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres seulement de l'exploitation
de mitry mory
ici les pédiluves et autoliv
désinfectants sont un passage obligé
pour le personnel en contact direct avec
les animaux plus de mini ferme ou
d'attelages sur le parc les percherons
les vaches et les bisons sont en
quarantaine
isolé du public mais bien vu comment ça
se passe actuellement la phobie s'il ya
donc on souhaitait être vraiment très
prudent nous on a fait venir aucune bête
récemment donc on n'aurait pas de raison
d'être de craindre une contamination sur
le département de seine-et-marne les
centres hippiques ne peuvent plus sortir
leur baisse de leur domaine plus de
concours hippique transport d'animaux et
promenades en forêt interdite cette
ferme pédagogique soit restée elle aussi
en quarantaine isolé depuis trois
semaines d'exploitation commence à avoir
des problèmes
malgré l'autorisation qu'on a reçu
récemment il ya eu contre indications
tout de suite ça donc en fait il ya plus
possibilité une feinte de l'attelage
donc beaucoup d'attelage en lots aussi
désolé
o des chevaux en extérieur ni
possibilité de sortie les centres
hippiques devront garder leurs bêtes à
l'écurie et patienter au moins trois
semaines si aucun autre cas ne se
déclare d'ici là un manque à gagner
important pour ces entreprises de
loisirs
l'épisode i en grande bretagne pourrait
échapper à tout contrôle le gouvernement
britannique s'appuyant sur un rapport
officiel envisage d'ici juin prochain
l'existence de plus de 4000 foyers
c'est pour cette raison que l'abattage
systématique du cheptel va commencer
dans les jours qui viennent plus d'un
demi million d'animaux sont concernés et
c'est sur ce site d'un ancien terrain
d'aviation dans le nord-ouest de
l'angleterre que seront enterrés à cinq
mètres de profondeur les carcasses de
deux cent mille bêtes
le ministère de l'agriculture
britannique vient de dévoiler
aujourd'hui sept premières zones
d'abattage
d'autres suivront vingt-quatre heures
après l'évasion spectaculaire de la
maison d'arrêt de draguignan les trois
prisonniers sont toujours en cavale et
aucune piste sérieuse ne se dessine la
voiture qu'ils ont utilisée a été
retrouvée ce matin près de grasse en
partie brûlé armé et dangereux les
fugitifs purger tous de langue peine la
police judiciaire est désormais chargée
de l'enquêté
olivier théron r2 potter la dernière
trace des évadés de draguignan cédant 7
504 volé hier matin que les trois hommes
et leurs complices ont certainement
rejoint un autre véhicule avant de
disparaître
les enquêteurs ont reconstitué le
parcours de leur spectaculaire évasion
d'abord à grimaud la prise en otage du
pilote d'hélicoptère draguignan ensuite
pour l'évasion proprement dite de la
maison d'arrêt atterrissage à auribeau
sur siagne
il est l'hélicoptère vole une voiture et
la brûle quelques kilomètres plus loin à
la roquette sur siagne
les quatre hommes serait alors parti en
direction de cannes une évasion de
professionnels il faut dire que les
hommes et notamment jean félix le cas
sont des durs proche du milieu corse et
du grand banditisme
ils n'ont rien laissé au hasard ils ont
par exemple utilisé des téléphones
portables volés pour communiquer avec
leurs comparses
le plan épervier en échec l'enquêté
confiée à la police judiciaire de nice
et de toulon elle s'annonce compliquée à
draguignan
la polémique grandit entre syndicats et
direction
c'est le manque de moyens pour assurer
la sécurité qui aurait finalement
favorisé la fuite de ces trois dangereux
malfaiteurs paris un nouveau maire
bertrand delanoë a été élu sans surprise
ce matin pour la première fois depuis
près d'un siècle la gauche est
majoritaire au conseil de paris
les femmes vont entrer en force à
l'hôtel de ville et c'est anne hidalgo
qui devient la première adjointe au
maire
retour sur cette séance d'intronisation
avec un maître mot répété à l'envi par
le nouveau maire est maintenant au
travail
reportage laurent hakim alexandre de
laval à paris c'est donc l'alternance et
il faut que ça se voit ça commence par
des parkings à vélo dans la cour c'est à
cela qu'on voit que les écolos ont pris
du galon à la mairie on verrouille même
le dit vélocipède car avec un peu de
mauvais esprit on se méfie encore de
l'ancienne équipe municipale
à droite c'est la soupe à la grimace
edouard balladur évite la presse
philippe séguin traverse la meute sans
un mot serge blisko le socialiste du 13e
sert de guide au petit nouveau qui
cherchent leur banc dans l'amphithéâtre
daniel vaillant n'a pas encore choisi
faudra-t-il l'appeler monsieur le
ministre d'intérieur ou monsieur le
maire du 18e après - donald valeur lui
il veut bien qu'on l'appelle encore
monsieur le maire pendant quelques
minutes c'est jean tiberi mais monsieur
le maire désormais ce sera lui bertrand
delanoë goûte donc à ces derniers
instants de tranquillité
une petite fournée de poignées de main y
compris à la nouvelle opposition on
aperçoit déjà anne hidalgo la future
première adjointe et voilà bertrand
delanoë élu avec le plein des 92 voix de
gauche
monsieur delanoë 92 voix élu
le premier maire socialiste à paris
depuis un siècle fait un bref discours
programme et remercie ses pairs à sa
façon certains ne comprennent pas ce
geste
certains le comprennent il vient de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée il veut
dire merci il veut dire je te salue et
il veut dire fraternité pour ma part
j'assumerai ma fonction dans la loyauté
la plus totale à l'égard de chaque
parisienne de chaque parisien
quelle que soit sa conviction encore une
ovation et puis cette petite touche
d'austérité finale sans laquelle
bertrand delanoë il n'aurait pas été
tout à fait lui-même
on va mettre au travail à 50 ans
bertrand delanoë grand vainqueur donc de
l'élection municipale à part et entre en
pleine lumière proche de lionel jospin
ancien porte parole du parti socialiste
il a longtemps travaillé sans rechercher
la notoriété
désormais il devra faire avec itinéraire
d'un militant chef tamer unanimité
c'était en 81 la première vie politique
de bertrand delanoë un jeune homme
ambitieux bombardées à tout juste 30 ans
et porte parole du tout-puissant paix il
y à unanimité au sein du parti
dans cette génération qui a découvert le
pouvoir après le 10 mai 81 il ya les
bons élèves du parti comme lionel jospin
et bertrand delanoë
tous deux ont appris quelques règles en
politique à la même école auprès d'un
même françois mitterrand et 20 ans plus
tard ceux qui connaissent bien le
nouveau maire de paris savent qu'il en
reste quelque chose a pris de françois
mitterrand la manière de faire de la
politique est aussi un peu ses séries tu
comme ça c'est pour les rites bain par
exemple il mange il est jeune toujours
avec les mêmes personnes le jour de vote
le jour du scrutin
après quelques années des clipse
bertrand delanoë y revient sur la scène
politique elle n'est plus nationale mais
parisien sa base de conquête c'est le
18ème là où il milite depuis toujours
avec daniel vaillant claude estier et un
certain lionel jospin en 95 la gauche
enlève six arrondissements et ouvre une
première brèche dans la forteresse
parisienne tenue par la droite mais de
temps à autre le tandem jospin delanoë
se reforme à chaque grande élection
présidentielle ou législative l'insi
présente l'autre donne des conseils en
communication trois quatre jours tous
nos porte-paroles valorise quatre
propositions
bertrand delanoë est il un candidat
crédible à la mairie de paris
il sait qu'il va devoir faire mentir
ceux qui en doutent et d'abord dans son
propre camp ce qui le regarde un peu de
haut qui pensent que seul un poids lourd
comme dominique strauss kahn ou jack
lang peut s'imposer en prenait la suite
c'est une certaine façon de faire de la
politique qui s'est finalement imposée
même la droite en convient est-ce qu'il
fallait prendre un maire de stature
internationale
ou est-ce qu'il fallait prendre un air
de proximité chirac avait réussi cette
synthèse on s'aperçoit que cette
synthèse y avait que chirac qu'il avait
réussi et bien je crois que les
parisiens donner la réponse
ils ont donné la réponse dans la
proximité c'est de la vraie clavel
officiel
premier maire socialiste élue à paris
depuis un siècle bertrand delanoë est
aussi l'un des très rares hommes
politiques à avoir révélé son
homosexualité
bref il a bousculé quelques règles
établies autres élections d'abord à
strasbourg où fabienne keller a été élu
par le conseil municipal le face à la
maire sortante socialiste catherine
trautmann
là aussi une élection sans suspense à 41
ans l'udf fabienne keller qui était la
seule candidate de l'émotion était
visible
elle a tenu à rendre hommage à l'action
de catherine trautmann et puis à lyon
sans surprise là aussi le socialiste
gérard collomb succède à raymond barre
il a aussitôt affirmé ne pas vouloir
être le maire d'un clan d'un groupe mais
celui de tous les lyonnais
revenons-en à l'exemple inédite de ce
village de gironde la droite et la
gauche ont fait alliance pour empêcher
l'élection de celui qui était arrivé en
tête le 18 mars dernier
voici les raisons évoquées aurélia
guillemin philippe ménard n'aime pas
beaucoup s'attarder dans le quartier et
parce qu'il n'y ait pas forcément invité
ici c'est le fief de mademoiselle
mussotte maire sortante de barsac de
droite comme lui c'est elle qui hier
l'empêcher de remporter l'hôtel de ville
il ya d'autres villages où il ya des
homosexuels ne se passent très calmement
bah oui
du fait qu'il a annoncé ça et il annoncé
avant à tous les médias
et moi je pense que ces sacs à toulouse
il y a un an et demi philippe ménard
alors conseiller municipal annoncé
publiquement son homosexualité
si aujourd'hui il n'est pas maire de
barsac c'est parce que la candidate de
droite a préféré s'allier aux
socialistes liberto panier agua dans
cette commune de 2000 habitants
c'est son adversaire de toujours quand
on voit que deux listes proposées se
mettre ensemble
je sais pas si c'est correct vis-à-vis
de la population vis-à-vis déjà je crois
qu'il faut être honnête aussi qu'ils
disent
nous nous opposons à philippe ménard
parce que nous ne voulons pas de merlot
sexuelle à barsac
disons les choses comme elles sont
envoyées ça prend cinq dix secondes si
pas plus homophobes que je suis un être
tout à fait moi je me trouve tout à fait
normal
certaines choses est majoritaire au
premier comme au second tour philippe
ménard restera pourtant conseiller
municipal donc on va pouvoir retrouver
bien mal me voir quant au nouveau maire
de barsac
il a eu bien du mal à enfiler les
chartes il va maintenant lui falloir la
portée
ce dimanche et celui de trois élections
législatives partielles d'abord avec le
retour espéré de dominique strauss kahn
sur la scène politique qui tente de
récupérer son poste de député dans le
val d'oise et nous retrouvons tout de
suite en direct à aalborg nicosie pour
les premières estimations bien ses
premières estimations nous disent
béatrice que nous allons nous revoir la
semaine prochaine pour un second tour en
effet la participation est actuellement
évaluée à 35 % sur la circonscription la
huitième du val d'oise
ce n'est sans doute pas suffisant pour
permettre à dominique strauss kahn
d'atteindre un score de 25 % des
inscrits une fois que tous les bulletins
auront été compté actuellement de
michoacan est effectivement en avance
mais pas suffisamment il y aura donc
très probablement un second tour dans
cette circonscription avec une
participation très décevante mais on s'y
attendait c'est ici le deuxième voire le
troisième dimanche où les électeurs sont
appelés à venir voter merci alban et
donc on se retrouvera dimanche prochain
nous n'avons pas pour l'instant les
résultats de toulouse où philippe
douste-blazy tentent d'emporter le siège
de député laissé vide par dominique
baudis désormais président du csa enfin
cannes le rpr bernard brochand brigue le
poste laissé vacant après le décès de la
députée udf louise moreau la semaine
sociale qui s'annonce ce risque d'être
perturbée d'abord dès demain dans les
transports très peu de bus de métro et
de tramway à lille lyon marseille
montpellier ou total d'une quarantaine
de villes de province les syndicats
réclament la retraite à 55 ans mais le
vrai point noir devrait se situer jeudi
avec une grève nationale à la sncf à
l'appel de toutes les fédérations
au centre des revendications les
salaires et les effectifs
l'actualité internationale avec
l'offensive de l'armée macédonienne à
tetovo une opération d'envergure qui
aurait permis aux forces
gouvernementales de reprendre le
contrôle des principales positions sur
les collines entourant la deuxième ville
du pays
le secrétaire général de l'otan
devraient arriver dès demain à skopje la
capitale crise en guinée
et à nouveau un déluge de feu s'abattant
sur les hauteurs de détruire les
autorités macédoniennes semble vouloir
en finir avec les combattants de lucho
cas qui depuis près de trois semaines
après les forces gouvernementales
hélicoptère blindé ont filmé toute la
matinée les villages sous contrôle des
rebelles john boehner dans les quartiers
du sud à majorité albanophone il ne
reste que des hommes tous sont
favorables à l'ue checa une voiture nos
guides
à l'arrivée un taxi criblé de balles
trois hommes et une femme
mitraillé par la police macédonienne
alors qu'il tentait de s'enfuir vers le
kosovo voisins et regardez ce qu'ils ont
fait regardez ce qui a fait la police ça
va mal ça c'est un taxi une voiture de
civils
mitraillé à l'armé automatique lagos des
villes et après il dit dans la scène où
le terrorisme 13 heures de nouveaux
clients vers leurs villages pour la
communauté albanaise une nouvelle
trahison ce village qui brûle c'est un
peu le nôtre cela on a des parents des
amis là-bas dans ce genre de guerre ont
rejoint dix jours sa propre communauté
l'objectif de l'armée macédonienne est
de repousser les combattants de loups
checa derrière ces montagnes au kosovo
mais lourdement armés elles risquent de
rapidement s'enliser face à une guérilla
extrêmement mobiles loup checa d hier a
ouvert un nouveau front à 12 kilomètres
seulement au nord de la capitale skopje
en fin d'après midi la première sortie
officielle de bertrand delanoë qui était
venu accueillir les membres de la
commission d'évaluation du comité
international olympique
pendant quatre jours ils vont juger
examiner la candidature de paris pour
les jeux de 2008 le mois précédent il
s'était déjà rendu à pékin qui est
candidat à un candidat de poids dans les
jeux olympiques pékin qui a failli
l'emporter pour les jo de l'an 2000
et pékin s'était lancé à cette époque
dans une politique de grands travaux que
l'on comparé à la muraille de chine
philippe rochot tristan ne brasse pas un
dimanche sans que la ville de pékin ne
mobilise les habitants pour la bataille
des jeux olympiques
ici les employés chinois des firmes
étrangères flambe des arbres sur les
collines dominant la capitale afin
d'arrêter les vents de sable
il faut que pékin soit présentable avant
la décision finale du comité olympique
et l'on redoute quelque peu la
candidature de paris
chez les vases réussi et après becker
mais je souhaite paris
mais pékin doit encore se battre pour
améliorer un environnement régulièrement
menacées par la pollution et la
sécheresse or il faut que pékin soit
vert pour être cité olympique
la ville a promis de débloquer 40
milliards de francs pour cela le
problème de l'environnement à pékin est
bien réelle il ya une grosse différence
avec paris toronto osaka c'est pourquoi
on a lancé un plan de lutte contre la
pollution qu'elle va durer jusqu'en 2007
le maire de pékin a voulu nous montrer
aussi que la sécurité serait assurée par
quelque quarante mille policiers
pékin dit on ici ne sera pas un nouveau
munich la ville redoutent pourtant que
la secte des falloon gang ne fasse à
double part
dans cette capitale de la chine où très
peu de gens parlaient une langue
étrangère on se mette à l'anglais
des cours gratuits sont donnés pour le
personnel hôtelier les chauffeurs de
taxi les conducteurs de bus ou même les
fonctionnaires qui répondaient ainsi à
l'appel du comité de quartier
ces cours d'anglais permettent
d'améliorer le niveau de la nation il
nous aide aussi à mieux comprendre
l'informatique alors des fonctionnaires
aux soldats de l'armée populaire c'est
tout pékin qui se mobilisent pour faire
de la capitale de la chine une cité qui
se veut accueillante
c'était l'une des deux conditions posées
pour sa candidature pour décrocher les
jeux olympiques la chine s'est engagée à
améliorer également la situation des
droits de l'homme
et là il reste beaucoup à faire mais
pékin n'oublie pas que c'est à cause de
ce problème des droits de l'homme que
les jeux olympiques de l'an 2000 lui ont
échappé de nouveaux pays font leur
rentrée à partir d'aujourd'hui dans
l'espace schengen permettant à quelques
24 millions de danois suédois finlandais
islandais norvégien de pouvoir désormais
voyager librement dans les autres pays
déjà signataires les explications de
jérôme benny chan tonnage symbolique
d'une barrière à l'aéroport de vienne en
97 destruction bien réelle d'un poste
douanier devenus inutiles en belgique en
99 et aujourd'hui les ministres allemand
et suédois de l'intérieur qui supprime
ce bureau de contrôle des passeports
c'est ça l'europe sans frontières qui
passe aujourd'hui de 10 à 15 pays avec
l'arrivée de cinq pays nordiques dont la
norvège et l'islande qui n'appartiennent
pas à l'union européenne mais décide
d'adhérer à ce principe communautaire de
libre circulation des personnes
24 millions d'européens en plus pourront
désormais circuler dans cet espace
schengen élargie où il n'est pas
nécessaire de présenter un passeport
pour passer d'un pays à l'autre
mais ici par exemple une simple carte
d'embarquement l'espace schengen c'est
aussi un contrôle renforcé aux
frontières extérieures pour contre
carrer l'immigration clandestine tâche
qui ne sera pas facilitée par
l'élargissement au nord qui veut dire
surveillance accrue en finlande par
exemple pays qui à 12 100 km de
frontière commune avec la russie dans
quelques heures à los angeles le
tout-hollywood assistera à la remise des
escarres grand favori cette année le
film gladiator et le metteur en scène
doublement nominé pour trafic avec
michael douglas erin brockovich avec
julia roberts
steven soderbergh côté français deux
espoirs sérieux mais rien n'est joué ni
pour juliette binoche ni pour le film
d'agnès jaoui le goût des autres
reportage de notre envoyé spécial
étienne une art les acheteurs de rêve
par star de cinéma interposés campent
depuis deux jours sur un trottoir de los
angeles pour espérer ce soir à percevoir
quelque chose et avec plus ou moins
d'assurance il tente de dresser la liste
des nominations française pour cette
73ème cérémonie des oscars d'hollywood a
duré à peine un chien était en fait
c'est un peu une julia roberts à la
française avec la grosse bouche en moins
chacun jugera du bien fondé de la
comparaison
juliette binoche après son oscar du
meilleur second rôle féminin il ya
quatre ans est de retour à hollywood
cette fois dans la catégorie des
meilleurs actrice pour son rôle dans
chocolat et leur apporte à faire pour
s'imposer à la grandissime favorite
l'américaine julia roberts acquis
juliette binoche promet d'ailleurs
sincèrement ce soir une belle récompense
ça fait quinze ans qu'elle travaille qu
elle fait beaucoup de films que c'est
une merveilleuse actrice qu'elle a
jamais été jamais de ce car je m'étais
vraiment reconnue en tant que qu'actrice
est reconnu par ses pairs quoi donc je
pense que son heure et vient et puis
dans un registre un tout petit peu plus
intimiste agnès jaoui lloret au lait
pour le goût des autres d'une nomination
dans la catégorie du meilleur film
étranger est venu elle en éternel
militante poursuivre son combat pour la
diversité des cultures et contre
l'hégémonie du cinéma américain dans une
fois ses fans question ils ont des bons
films c'est pas les américains mais
simplement que je pense que les cultures
différentes doivent survivre moi j'en ai
besoin pour viser besoin de voir des
films italiens japonais
j'en ai besoin et je pense que c'est
important mais ce spectacle là que l'on
répétait encore ces dernières heures
jusque dans ses moindres détails et
évidemment est avant tout une affaire de
gros sous
plusieurs centaines de millions de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde
seront scotchés cette nuit devant leur
téléviseur et cette cérémonie des oscars
devrait cette année se résumer à un duel
au sommet entre les muscles des
guerriers de gladiateurs et l'agilité
des acteurs chinois de tigres et dragons
ont sans doute fixé au terme d'une
cérémonie qui devrait durer près de cinq
heures pour trois jours le printemps du
cinéma avec des tarifs très compétitifs
pour les cinéphiles être dans quelques
5000 salles de france va francs par
billet d'initiatives qui est déjà
largement fait ses preuves
portrait d'une comédienne de théâtre de
grand talent catherine samie joutes
depuis près d'un demi-siècle à la
comédie française
aujourd'hui elle se produit au théâtre
du vieux colombier dans les danseurs de
la pluie une pièce australienne michel
soulève ici
christian galley la comédie française
c'est dans cette même logique que depuis
45 ans
catherine samie peaufinent ce héros de
molière à audiberti elle a su donner vie
à des centaines de personnages qu'elle
incarne soubrette souveraine avec le
même talent et la même énergie et des
souvenirs incroyables
le texte ne me quitte pas elle garde
soit environ aux notes
entre la comédie française et catherine
samie c'est une longue histoire d'amour
lassé des petits mots de céline ma fille
quand elle était toute petite elle écrit
vers un petit un petit mot qui est le
porte bonheur au théâtre c'est à dire
merde rôle mais toujours affectueux
ah oui
allez catherine samie se joue avec
ironie de la tradition pour toutes ses
qualités
les comédiens du français l'ont élu à la
charge de doyen une reconnaissance qui
ne freine en rien sa boulimie de travail
dans la salle du comité de lecture elle
se prépare à devenir l'impératrice
d'autriche marie thérèse gratitude elle
est magnifique je la connais depuis nous
avons fait nos premiers pas en sont
presque
voilà le maître mot de catherine samie
s'est avancé
c'est une belle maison c'est très
étrange parce qu'on travaille dès des
auteurs nous voler comme un peu commune
comme des vagues à se renouvelle
madame le doyen n'est jamais là où on
l'attend ce soir là voici pauvresse dans
le désert australien
ce n'est pas vraiment une pièce rude et
tragique d'un auteur reconnu au théâtre
français est toujours on a toujours
pensé pour jouer comment lierre ce n'est
pas vrai ça a toujours été brassés tu te
rappelles quand j'étais gosse je te le
chatelier pouvait de chatouilles l enfer
vie c est resté chatouilleuse catherine
samie c'est une aventurière du ter
c'est la fin de ce journal j'en appelle
les deux principaux titres à un avion
d'air caraïbes s'écrase à l'atterrissage
à saint-barthélemy hyland la catastrophe
20 morts la plupart d'entre eux étaient
des touristes venant de la métropole les
causes du drame sont encore inconnues
l'élection ce matin de bertrand delanoë
qui devient le premier maire de gauche
de la capitale il la choisit une femme
anne hidalgo comme première adjointe et
invité le conseil de paris à se mettre
au travail au plus vite
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet 20h52 votre film du dimanche le
collectionneur avec morgan freeman
23h55 que le dernier journal du régulier
demain 7h 50 ans les 4 vérités gérard
morin recevra renaud dutreil député udf
de l'aisne à 13h le journal gérard holtz
à 20h que c'est riant et en deuxième
partie de soirée mme ont croisé thème de
l'émission la justice face aux victimes
guy georges les disparus d'auxerre et
aussi toutes les affaires de pédophilie
arlette chabot et alain duhamel
recevront la garde des sceaux marylise
lebranchu
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sont rentrés
il